really how's your approach to performing
changed over the years as a Bothan actor
in a comedian as well a change is very
gradually you know did you get okay get
more nervous than I used to I don't know
why I should be but it stays pretty much
the same and gradually graduate the
changes to gradual like age itself that
you don't really notice it because I'm
37 in my head I haven't really changed
since then what you do to deal with
those nerves and if you said you get a
bit more nervous now yeah do it seems to
be getting getting more nervous as years
go by perhaps bomb to other people this
is same for everybody I did you with
those nerves think just kind of matter
to you know take it easy because what
you really want to do is take nup but if
you can sort of make yourself relax a
bit the same with you if you're the
trouble is in Britain the teacher will
see a Connelly concentrate so you go hmm
but if you go to concentrate you're much
better to relax so that the temptation
is to tighten up so the best thing to do
is to try and relax just take it easy
it's difficult to lay on go once you've
got its get it you've mastered it now no
I'm getting there
you